[Música]
Argentina comenzó a calentar motores de
Cara a un año electoral de suma
importancia para el futuro de la
Argentina postpandemia que enfrenta
muchos retos a nivel económico social y
en general de estabilidad así como
Argentina lo da todo en la cancha en los
partidos de fútbol Pues ahora se la
jugará en las urnas para elegir
presidente vicepresidente 130 diputados
y 24 senadores nacionales además de
otros tantos procesos electorales a
nivel provincial y regional
el calendario es el siguiente se los
explicamos sin duda Argentina nos va a
tener muy ocupados hablando de ella
Durante este año con diferentes comicios
el 13 de agosto es el pitazo inicial con
las paso que son las primarias abiertas
simultáneas y obligatorias ahí digamos
que se configuran quienes van a ser los
candidatos que se van a enfrentar el 22
de octubre en las presidenciales de ser
necesario hay una segunda vuelta el 19
de noviembre pero lo que sinceramente
encendió los motores fueron los primeros
anuncios de los políticos y de algunos
funcionarios que están interesados en
llegar a la casa rosada no todos están
100% seguros de llegar a ser candidatos
para el 22 de octubre pero son las
cartas que ya comienzan a ponerse sobre
la mesa para los votantes para los
ciudadanos argentinos del lado
oficialista los nombres que comienzan a
sonar son el de Eduardo de Pedro
ministro del interior muy cercano al
kirchnerismo Sergio massa ministro de
economía que no no se ha pronunciado
claramente al respecto pero suena entre
diferentes sectores también está el
actual presidente Alberto Fernández
quien ha manejado el tema muy
diplomáticamente ha evadido esta
pregunta a los diferentes medios de
comunicación algunos lo dan como un
seguro candidato para las primarias pero
no se ha manifestado de manera
contundente del lado de la oposición son
varios los candidatos Como por ejemplo
Horacio Rodríguez larreta actual el jefe
del gobierno de la ciudad Autónoma de
Buenos Aires el 23 de febrero presentó
oficialmente su candidatura todo lo
contrario con la ex ministra de
seguridad Patricia bullrich que todavía
no ha hecho un anuncio oficial pero
lleva ya varios meses trabajando en
diferentes actividades que uno podría
pensar que son actividades de campaña no
solamente en la provincia de Buenos
Aires y en la capital Federal en la
parte de la capital Argentina sino
también en algunas provincias argentinas
Elisa carrió presentó su candidatura o
precandidatura de manera oficial las
dudas están en torno al expresidente
Mauricio macri que tampoco ha dado
señales muy claras de aspirar a un
segundo mandato presidencial al mando de
Argentina y tampoco es Claro si la
diputada y ex gobernadora de la
provincia de Buenos Aires María Eugenia
Vidal se lanza o no a esta contienda
presidencial Vidal fue muy clara y dijo
si macri es candidato yo no voy a
competir Pero ha dado algunos indicios
que podrían llevar a pensar que podría
ser una candidata
también hay que mencionar el nombre de
Javier milei del partido libertad la
libertad avanza que se perfila también
como otro candidato también ha comenzado
a sonar ya en diferentes sectores de la
sociedad Argentina así entonces cómo
están las cosas para esta para este
inicio de carrera presidencial en
Argentina Quiénes son entonces Esas
fichas sólidas que van a aguantar hasta
el 22 de octubre para esos comicios se
lanzará Fernández se lanzará macri a una
nueva contienda electoral Qué piensan
los argentinos cómo está entre la
población el sentimiento electoral hay
entusiasmo o pasan estas elecciones
simplemente como un momento de coyuntura
de un poco de incertidumbre y no hay
ningún entusiasmo por parte de los
argentinos por eso hoy en el debate de
France 24 Argentina y Su futuro
presidencial quién podrá gobernarlos
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
Elsa lente rosas ella es directora de
ciencia política de la Universidad de
Buenos Aires también está con nosotros
Ignacio él es analista político de la
Universidad Católica Argentina también
es analista senior en millie global
advisors ustedes nuestros televidentes
también hacen parte de este debate
pueden dejar sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook en
instagram ustedes ya saben no se
encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta numeral el debate
f24 y a mí me encuentran como arroba
santilogo en Twitter no olviden también
que todos los contenidos del programa
están en Apple podcast en Spotify en
deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Elsa Elsa Gracias por estar con
nosotros en el debate de France 24 Punto
de partida que opinión tiene usted de
este inicio de la carrera presidencial
todavía digamos que esto está en una
etapa muy inicial pero cuáles son sus
impresiones de estos candidatos que
empiezan a a sonar esos nombres en los
medios argentinos y hacer parte de la
conversación cotidiana de los ciudadanos
Bueno muy buenas tardes Santiago sí como
quedó demostrado hay una sobreabundancia
candidatos tanto desde el oficialismo
como de la oposición Todavía es muy
temprano como para hacer algunas
predicciones sobre las posibilidades de
la competitividad que tenga tanto la
oposición como el oficialismo pero lo
que vemos es bastante desordenada
todavía la tanto en en las posibilidades
de candidatos el oficialismo como de la
misma oposición y por el lado de la
sociedad lo que se ve es una todavía muy
amplia muy profunda desafección política
la gente está muy muy
digamos no no hay no hay no genera
entusiasmo las elecciones nos genera
entusiasmo en general los candidatos que
que se observan en hoy que han sido
mencionados Pero bueno suponemos que
esto se va a ir decantando a medida que
que justamente queden definidos quienes
van a jugar efectivamente claramente
esto poco a poco los motores se Irán
calentando y esto irá enganchando aún
más a los ciudadanos argentinos una vez
se vaya configurando quienes van a ser
los los candidatos Ignacio le doy la
palabra bienvenido También usted al
programa Gracias por acompañarnos y su
su análisis su opinión sobre este inicio
de la campaña estas primeras estos
primeros nombres que se dan a conocer
bueno Yo diría que me parece que la
política está en una conversación muy
diferente a la conversación de la calle
no
discuten candidaturas Y la verdad que la
prioridad de la sociedad está en otro
lado más en el día a día en la inflación
Me parece que falta mucho llegado el
contexto de crisis económica que
atraviesa la Argentina
el escenario es muy cambiante lo que sí
diría Es que creo que hay una muy alta
chance alternancia dada la mala gestión
del actual gobierno y dar una tendencia
regional desde abril del año 2018 ningún
partido gobernante en un contexto
democrático Ha logrado ser
Ignacio continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa hablemos de las caras
que he mencionado algunos algunos de
estos figuras de la política Argentina
incluso de la de la política regional
quiénes son esas caras fuertes Quiénes
se muestran ya con cierta ventaja dentro
de los comentarios y dentro de la
perspectiva de los argentinos por llevar
una amplia trayectoria política y por
haber también estado en diferentes
cargos en diferentes gobiernos
está desenganchada Y eso se nota cuando
uno mira las encuestas no que cuesta ver
a alguien que
despunte el liderazgo claro no
la figura con mayor intención de Voto si
uno hiciera una encuesta paradójicamente
la expresidenta y actual vicepresidente
Argentina lo que pasa es que ella no
llegaría sería probablemente la figura
más votada individualmente primaria Sí
pero perdería llevaría su partido a la
derrota no entonces
no hay en la ciudadanía no hay hoy
ningún tipo de interés ni por la
política ni por las elecciones es algo
que está la ciudadanía está más
preocupada por la dinámica de la
inflación digo claro corriendo con una
inflación
ese es un tema que vamos a analizar más
adelante en el programa Quiero
preguntarle a Elsa para usted Elsa
quiénes son esas caras fuertes Quiénes
son esos que tienen una amplia
trayectoria política que pueden empezar
a pararse Bien dentro del escenario
presidencial
bueno según las encuestas que tenemos
hasta el momento y coincido con lo que
señalaba Ignacio la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández de kirchner es la que
posee lo que llamamos un piso ya muy muy
alto de garantizado de votantes de apoyo
electoral pero también su techo
electoral es este es bajo o sea que
tiene y todos los candidatos del
oficialismo que que ustedes mencionaron
en la placa inicial
en un altísimo nivel de imagen negativa
más del 60% de imagen negativa es decir
que
tienen enormes dificultades como para
enfrentar esta campaña electoral por
delante por otro lado la novedad como lo
mencionaste también al pasar se
corresponde con una figura una tercera
fuerza distinta que Javier milei que
viene en un partido una ideología más
libertaria que
que plantea por el momento una intención
de Voto que puede abundar en el 15% pero
estamos hablando Todavía de escenarios
muy muy preliminares porque al no tener
definidos exactamente quienes van a ser
los precandidatos es muy difícil
tener mediciones más precisas sobre esto
no y del lado del de la oposición Bueno
por el momento el jefe de gobierno de la
ciudad de Buenos Aires Horacio Rodríguez
larreta y patri
ministra de del gobierno de presidente
macri son los que de alguna manera están
más encaminados hacia hacia encabezar la
elección agregaría también que en ese
pelotón de candidatos del oficialismo
tiene que resolverse hacia dentro de la
coalición perdón de la oposición hacia
dentro de la coalición de la oposición
la relación con los socios no decir con
la coalición cívica el caso de lisa
carrió y con el partido de radicalismo
que tiene también sus dos precandidatos
no Gerardo morales y Facundo mares que
todavía están muy Bajos en las encuestas
pero que bueno la coalición necesita
resolver hacia adentro Cómo va a llegar
al a las a las paso no a las elecciones
primarias bueno como ustedes lo dicen
estas estos nombres preliminares generan
poca expectativa y poca emoción entre
los argentinos ya ustedes mismos lo
dicen hay una hay la sociedad Argentina
que está enfocada más en otros temas
viéndolo desde afuera de las fronteras
argentinas hemos visto un país que está
muy polarizado muy dividido a lo largo
de los últimos años esto Cómo se puede
reflejado en este inicio de campaña en
este escenario electoral esto con Ánimo
de profundizar en eso que ustedes ya han
comenzado a mencionar Ignacio de que
todavía no hay un sentimiento de
elecciones electorales no hay candidatos
que emocionen dentro de los dentro de
los argentinos esta polarización cómo se
va a ver reflejada en estos comicios o
Usted cree que eso ya comienza a
cerrarse un poco
yo no creo que la polarización en
términos ideológicos sea tan alta más
bien me parece que hay dos minorías
intensas
el que una menor intensa kinerita y una
menor intensa muy anti kirchnerista y el
grueso de la sociedad que no está en ese
en esa onda si tuviéramos tanta
polarización habría muchísimo más
interés por la política y no lo hay digo
por consumir noticias de política que
hay polarización ideológica en el
sentido que hay dos extremos muy
chiquitos minorías intensas pero no eso
que bien reporte es edelman de la
Argentina con el país más polarizado del
mundo me parece que es totalmente
incorrecto
Elsa su opinión esta polarización Es
evidente es palpable para estas
elecciones esto Cómo va a repercutir en
esto de proceso electoral
la gran pregunta me parece que es
precisamente eso si los candidatos
tienen que seguir apostando agudizar y
profundizar lo que llamamos acá la
grieta es decir seguir polarizando esos
generar más enfrentamiento político y
biológico o si por el contrario Creo yo
que es así que la gente está la sociedad
está muy cansada de esos enfrentamientos
entre la clase política como decía
también Ignacio
las que la gente está preocupada de
otros temas entonces la La pregunta es
si en realidad lo que espera la sociedad
y lo que va a votar la sociedad en
agosto y luego en octubre es candidatos
que apuesten más a la moderación es
decir a superar ese enfrentamiento que
que está haciendo fogoneado desde la
política principalmente es decir
resumiendo la pregunta es si
te apuesta a profundizar esa
polarización
la sociedad va a acompañar más una
postura moderada
Elsa en ese orden y te hace esta
polarización algunos años atrás no es
solamente un caso exclusivo de Argentina
lo vemos en buena parte de América
Latina esto qué frutos diopolíticamente
para los gobiernos de turno generar
estas discusiones estas confrontaciones
en el caso argentino benefició en algo
en la política Argentina benefició a
alguien en particular algún Movimiento
Político en particular o simplemente
sirvió para generar una alternancia de
poder y basta
Elsa
yo creo que sí precisamente
precisamente la la digamos tanto los
gobiernos de Cristina kirchner como el
propio cambiemos ese enfrentamiento
entre macri y Cristina kirchner Mauricio
macri Cristina es producto de ese de del
funcionamiento y del rédito de los
beneficios que de alguna por
diferenciación
obtienen las los espacios políticos
enfrentados y y hay candidatos dentro
del oficialismo y de la oposición que
siguen tratando de usufructuar esa ese
esos beneficios que eventualmente puede
generar la grieta
la polarización Así que yo yo creo que
esta es la la forma en la que la
política se manejó en las últimas
elecciones en las últimos recambios y
traspaso presidenciales piensen que las
dos grandes espacios
sumados llegan más del 80 por ciento
poco más del 80% de del electorado O sea
que esa polarización
se corresponde con un resultado
electoral también de de dos grandes
espacios políticos pero hoy creo que sí
adelante Elsa tranquila termine su idea
no no que creo que de alguna manera hay
en esta oportunidad me parece que ya hay
un agotamiento de parte de la sociedad
lo dicen las encuestas las mediciones de
opinión no la gente está un poco ya ya
agotada de del enfrentamiento entre la
clase política entre los dirigentes
políticos y que no resuelven los las
necesidades de la sociedad bueno los
argentinos no son los únicos que están
cansados de esta polarización eso
también se ve reflejado en Brasil en
Colombia en Venezuela en varios países
de América Latina es una realidad que
tal parece se ve
en muchos países de la región Ignacio su
opinión sobre lo que deja estos años de
división estos años de polarización de
enfrentamiento político algo para
rescatar de estos años de enfrentamiento
cree usted que hay algo que podamos
rescatar de ahí
no nada es básicamente la Argentina es
un país que tiene una economía estancada
desde el año 2011 donde
se ha reintroducido
términos políticos que estaban
erradicados hace mucho tiempo muy
denigratorios por ejemplo y por ejemplo
el a los antiperonistas se le decía
gorilas no importa Por qué término muy
efectivo y ese término se restarló en
los primeros años de este siglo este el
cristianismo tuvo mucho que ver en su
discurso en ver al adversario como un
enemigo Y de alguna manera
contagiosa lógica al resto del sistema
político yo creo que esto no no deja
nada de positivo
Ignacio pasando Usted lo ha mencionado
Ya varias veces en sus intervenciones
los argentinos Están preocupados en
otras cosas no solamente porque están en
temporada de verano todavía no termina y
están distraídos con otras cosas pero
Cuáles pueden ser esos temas que van a
abarcar Esta carrera presidencial estas
campañas hay muchos problemas en este
país después de la pandemia de Kobe 19
al gobierno le ha costado un poco esa
cara adelante la economía pero desde el
punto de vista de ustedes Cuáles van a
ser esos ejes de las campañas Ignacio
comienzo con usted
bueno la principal preocupación de la
sociedad según lo que marcan las
encuestas es la inflación no me parece
que conforme avance el año vamos a ver
también que el empleo empieza a hacer
una preocupación por la desaceleración
de la actividad económica comenzó en el
segundo semestre el año pasado y después
de eso la inseguridad claramente
y la preocupación hacia adelante no que
quién logra sacar a la Argentina del
estancamiento económico piensen que
desde 2011 si uno mira la evolución del
ingreso per cápita Argentina está
estancada Sí y la pobreza no digo
probablemente vamos a ver niveles de
pobreza
cercanos a los que vimos cuando se
produjo el colapso de la convertibilidad
sin que hace 20 años más de 20 años
entonces esos temas Me parece que van a
estar en el medio del debate economía
seguridad y pobreza Elsa qué más se
puede decir de estas necesidades de los
argentinos temas de campaña
no esos son las prioridades en primer
lugar van a tener que enfrentar el
problema de la inflación El problema del
desempleo el problema de la inseguridad
y agregaría al cuarto tema pero que está
muy por debajo de de las mediciones de
interés en la sociedad pero que siempre
aparece que es el de la corrupción de
todas maneras no no tengo expectativas
de que en las campañas electorales del
de los distintos candidatos haya
propuestas demasiado concretas Sobre qué
es lo que se va a hacer para resolver
varios de estos asuntos pero de todas
maneras me me parece que que es
importante destacar que varios de estas
cuestiones necesitan un acuerdo apuntar
hacia un acuerdo
un acuerdo general que donde participen
muchos sectores políticos económicos
gremiales porque muchas de estas
decisiones que que seguramente van a ser
necesarias
requieren de consensos de largo plazo no
es decir decisiones y estrategias y
políticas que se adopten Un gobierno y
que necesariamente pasen también y sean
sostenidas en los siguientes gobiernos
Así que yo creo que
sería incluso más oportuno Y supongo que
en eso apuntarán varios de los
candidatos es a construir una una
posición de de mayor acuerdo sobre
lineamientos y políticas públicas de
largo plazo Elsa eso son políticas y tal
vez problemas muy internos del país que
hay por ejemplo de la del liderazgo de
Argentina en la región esto pasa un
segundo plano dada toda esta compleja
situación que está viviendo Argentina o
cree que de pronto pueda haber una
iniciativa por parte de alguno de estos
candidatos de tratar de llevar otra vez
Argentina a una posición de Liderazgo a
nivel mercosur a nivel de Suramérica
como lo ha sido en otros momentos de la
historia
en donde en este escenario actual está
un poco rezagada y está muy metida en
los problemas internos en donde como
ustedes dicen Pues las soluciones no son
de la noche a la mañana pero pero la
comunidad internacional y buena parte de
latinoamérica extraña es el liderazgo
Argentino
extraña liderazgo argentino y creo que
extraña coherencia en la política
exterior esta política exterior ha sido
completamente la de este gobierno
errática contradictoria con idas y
vueltas
ha cambiado su posición en distintas
áreas particularmente en temas referidos
a democracia a la promoción y defensa de
los Derechos Humanos en los países de la
región en países donde están sufriendo
verdaderamente retrocesos autoritarios
entonces
la política exterior de este gobierno en
ese sentido
ha perdido el prestigio y la reputación
que tuvo en el pasado en cuestiones y en
temas en los que siempre se sobresalió
de alguna manera entonces me parece que
que tiene en la política exterior hay un
proceso de de necesario de reconstruir
una coherencia una línea de de
principios y que de alguna manera
generen también previsibilidad en los
otros actores no en los países de la
región y bueno y también el compromiso
de la participación en las instituciones
regionales este sin una mirada adaptada
a la ideología es decir
respetando las las particularidades de
los gobiernos de los países vecinos y la
región es decir no someter O atar su
lineamiento de política exterior a la
afinidad ideológica que se tenga o no
con esos gobiernos que creo que eso fue
un un este error de de esta actual la
administración y que generó demasiado
ruidos y demasiados tensiones abiertas
con varios países vecinos Ignacio le doy
tiempo para que usted haga su aporte sin
necesidad de decir algo sobre este tema
de la política exterior y el liderazgo
argentino y le amplía un poco la
pregunta sobre
Cómo llegan las grandes fuerzas
políticas a este escenario preelectoral
Cómo llega la coalición del oficialismo
Y cómo llega la coalición de la
oposición a este escenario preelectoral
veíamos por lo menos lo puede leer uno
en varios medios argentinos que el
oficialismo llega un poco
fracturado que llega como con divisiones
cuatro senadores se salieron de esta
coalición muchos decían que esto era una
evidencia de que efectivamente esa
coalición oficial pues nunca había
logrado como asentar bien sus bases a la
hora de gobernar Cuáles su análisis
bueno yendo la cuestión del liderazgo Yo
diría que para tener liderazgo hay que
tener capacidades Sí y hay que tener
también prestigio no hard Power y soft
Power y me parece que la Argentina no
cuenta con ninguna de las dos cosas en
este momento que por una cuestión de
vacío que hubo en América Latina el
presidente Fernández trató de ser como
el interlocutor privilegiado con
Washington este argentino ocupó la
presidencia de la celac y fue sucedida
por senquitines lo cual revela un
poquito la irrelevancia de la celac no
este así que yo no veo eso de tratar de
volver a ocupar liderazgo primero van a
tener va a tener que ocuparse de
resolver las cuestiones internas
respecto Cómo llegan las coaliciones Me
parece que las dos coaliciones se
enfrentan problemas distintos
El problema del frente de todos es que
en altamente probable que termine una
derrota electoral no Y entonces y todos
sus candidatos como bien dijo Elsa tiene
una alta imagen negativa no el problema
de la coalición opositora principal de
Juntos por el cambio es lo opuesto no
que lleva que el interna sea como casi
como una una lucha frasticida que es
está la percepción instalada de que se
va a ganar la elección Entonces los
candidatos creen que el que gana la Paz
es el próximo presidente no Y eso lleva
a que la interna sea bastante violenta y
me parece que ahí hay un problema no
porque no perciben esa virulencia cansa
el votante no Entonces yo digo en varios
países de la región hemos visto procesos
de desinstitucionalización de los
sistemas de partidos me pregunto si la
Argentina no se está exponiendo a eso
Elsa que puede decir usted al respecto
Solo que agregaría porque coincido con
lo que señalaba también Ignacio lo que
quedaría es la particular situación en
la que atraviesa el oficialismo al
frente de todos no un presidente que
todavía no se sabe si va a intentar ir a
la reelección que mantiene viva Esa esa
posibilidad justamente para no verse
licuado su poder no decir Bueno si ya se
se anuncia como un presidente que no va
a la reelección directamente
es la figura del pato rengo como se lo
llama no entonces el primer lugar es esa
la particular y peculiar situación a la
que está el presidente que ni siquiera
se sabe va a ir a la reelección y que
además se va a someter a una elección
primaria junto con posibles suministros
eso es una una situación muy particular
nunca lo hemos visto en la política
Argentina Así que la la peculiaridades
esa y con respecto al al a la oposición
yo creo que
lo señalaría que además de que
evidentemente hay hay más posibilidades
de que la oposición gane las las
elecciones existe dentro de la posición
natural de presidente macri que
pretende actuar y que actúa como el gran
elector hacia adentro
el el que segura o Posiblemente no sea
candidato pero que sí tenga la
posibilidad de definir los lineamientos
que puedan asumir sus candidatos de de
la fuerza política en la que de la que
es parte no y su liderazgo entonces
Elsa usted dice que es un escenario muy
particular efectivamente lo es
pocos indicios hay de si el presidente
Fernández aspira a una reelección o no
Si lo va a hacer o no pero desde su
análisis Usted cree que el presidente se
va a lanzar se va a exponer a unas paso
frente a sus ministros y aspirar a una
reelección en ese escenario cuando
Aparentemente la tendencia y y el ánimo
no está a favor del oficialismo cree
usted que se lanza
la opinión digamos la opinión positiva
de que tiene la sociedad sobre el
presidente está por el piso decir el
nivel de rechazo de su imagen y de la
gestión de gobierno es altísima Entonces
si mirara si mirara esos datos
seguramente no lo haría y además está
haciendo presionado por la propia
internamente por sus sus propios socios
de la coalición no del sector que lidera
la la vicepresidenta y otros sectores
dentro de todos lo están presionando
para que no vaya la reelección Así que
yo creo que tratará de mantener las
riendas hasta último momento Ignacio
Fernández
no yo creo que no va a ir y el peor
escenario que se muestre muy terco a la
hora de pretender y llevar al frente de
todos a una candidatura con él a la
cabeza una fórmula apreciada con la
cabeza el kirchnerismo le va a vaciar el
frente de todos tan simple como esto
Solo y con una muy mala elección el
peronismo no puede permitirse tener un
candidato tan malo e ir a lo que
probablemente sea la peor elección de su
historia y del otro lado de la moneda en
la oposición macri se lanza o no Porque
ya sabemos cómo son nuestras jugadas
políticas que se la pasan durante varios
meses diciendo que no van a lanzarse que
no tienen ninguna intención y al último
momento dan la sorpresa y se lanzan
argumentando que sienten un llamado del
pueblo que los votantes así lo pedían y
lo llevan planeando varios meses macri
irá por ese segundo mandato
Ignacio tampoco creo que dado el nivel
de rechazo que tiene la provincia de
Buenos Aires que es el distrito que
representa el 38% del padrón
no no se va no se va a presentar va a
seguir manteniendo el misterio eso no me
cabe duda porque va a tratar de negociar
posiciones
con Los candidatos de su espacio pero a
priori si tengo que jugarme diría que no
que no va a ser y Elsa coincide
coincido con lo que decía Ignacio lo
dije también antes no me parece que la
posición de macri en esta oportunidad es
tratar de crear esa incertidumbre sobre
si se escandidato o no al estilo de
Cristina kirchner no es como un acto
reflejo esto es un espejo y esperar
hasta último momento qué es lo que lo
que sucede también del lado de El
oficialismo pero
ambos casos los tanto Cristina kirchner
como Mauricio macri con dos figuras que
les costaría ganar en la en un balotaje
es decir son las figuras de las que
tienen menores probabilidades de ganar
en una segunda vuelta y al final se hace
un lado de la izquierda o derecha
terminan haciendo las mismas estrategias
no solo en Argentina sino que lo veo no
repitiéndose el mismo guión en otros
países de América Latina vamos llegando
al bloque final del programa quiero que
hagamos las conclusiones de lo que
significa pues este inicio ya de esta
del termómetro electoral en Argentina es
muy significativo lo que pase en este
país vamos a estar como lo decía yo
alguien al inicio en el programa vamos a
estar muy pendientes de este país
suramericano a lo largo de este año por
toda la campaña y lo que se viene a
nivel político hasta el 10 de diciembre
cuando tome posesión el nuevo presidente
conclusiones de lo que deja entonces
este arranque de las
campañas y se le puede decir así y
también quiero preguntarles rápidamente
que deja el gobierno de Alberto
Fernández que ya empieza la recta final
y ya uno puede hacer un balance de lo
que fue su gestión comienzo con Elsa
para terminar con Ignacio
bueno los datos están a la vista Un
gobierno que lidera a nivel mundial
una economía con altísima inflación es
una inflación que casi llegó al 100% 40%
de la población en la línea de pobreza
una pobreza estructural que avanza sobre
todo más del 60% se toma en cuenta la
pobreza de los niños es decir hay
muchísimos datos económicos y sociales
que se han agravado profundamente
durante esta durante la gestión del
presidente Fernández de manera que en el
en el plano económico deja una gran
decepción el plano económico y social y
yo agregaría también los datos referidos
a educación que como resultado o efecto
de la pandemia se han empeorado
fuertemente Entonces el el digamos el
balance
es bastante decepcionante para la
sociedad Argentina Ignacio su opinión
conclusión para el cierre Bueno yo
quisiera decir que coincido plenamente
con todo lo que dijo Elsa y agregaría
una cosa esta gestión de con tremendo
daño para la investidura presidencial
cuando la hoy vicepresidenta Cristina
Fernández en 2019 anunció que ella iba a
ir por la vicepresidencia que iba a
llevar como candidato presidente a su ex
jefe de gabinete porque había estado en
amistad durante varios años Alberto
Fernández mucha gente se comenzó a
preguntar quién iba a tener el poder
efectivamente cómo iba a ser esta
experiencia bueno
algunos pocos colegas dijimos Esto va a
terminar mal hubo muchos que dijeron que
Alberto Fernández iba a traicionar iba a
armar una base de poder cosa que no
ocurrió esto es un daño tremendo al
investigar Residencial sí tener una
figura como Alberto Fernández ya que el
daño institucional dirá que no es menor
y lo que decía él antes de la política
exterior las señales que que ha dado la
política exterior Argentina el zigzagueo
que es simplemente un reflejo del caos
interno que es en frente de todos es un
daño terrible al software de la
Argentina
importante esa reflexión Ignacio Elsa yo
les agradezco mucho que hayan hecho este
análisis para la audiencia de France 24
en América Latina hoy un poco de
pedagogía sobre la política de este país
que tiene un escenario muy complejo a
nivel económico de a nivel pues ustedes
ya lo decían a nivel internacional sobre
el liderazgo que tiene que ejercer este
país les agradezco a los dos por haber
estado con nosotros ya ustedes lo saben
les recuerdo las fechas rápidamente 13
de agosto son las paso que son las
primarias internas luego el 22 de
octubre vienen las presidenciales luego
tenemos una segunda vuelta el 19 de
noviembre y finalmente la toma de
Posesión presidencial el 10 de diciembre
este año estaremos hablando de política
Argentina a lo largo de lo que resta del
2023 país importante para la región de
América Latina a ustedes Muchas gracias
por la sintonía en nombre de todo el
equipo técnico Les agradecemos haber
estado con nosotros la producción del
programa hoy en dupla Laura garzón y
Luis Fernando Montes la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera muchísimas gracias y Pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales ya lo saben sigan
con nosotros
[Música]